[Musique]
alors ça fait un taux lire tout le monde
l'a défoncé Louane qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Gilles moi je la comprends là
parce que elle est accompagnée de son
enfant voilà c'est pour moi c'est ça qui
change tout quand on est seul on ne peut
pas refuser mais là je pense qu'elle a
voulu un réflexe maternelle ou parental
de protéger son enfant donc je la
comprends pour ça voilà non surtout que
surtout que hola on entend pas bien mais
quand on écoute vraiment de près elle
dit après où est le problème tu passes à
côté des gens et tu leur dis je reviens
après elle comptait revenir toute seule
sans son enfant je vois pas du tout où
est la polémique alors c'est
politiquement correct complètement on
n'est pas des objets on n'est pas des
gens qu'on balade moi je peux te dire
que dans la rue parfois les gens
t'arrêtent avec une grosse fierté et tu
dis on peut faire une photo
de la casquette tu peux enlever tes
lunettes tu peux faire ça tu peux faire
un sourire toi tu as des lunettes tu es
machin tes trucs bah non j'enlève pas
tout je suis pas ta poupée c'est un
métier je passe à la télé tu es où tu
aimes pas on n'est pas à la disposition
des gens quand c'est mal de savoir
parfois c'est très mal demandé Cyril il
y a un moment donné je vais arriver je
te jure ben si les gens ils arrivent
vas-y poteau
lève ton slip
non mais c'est vrai tu vois le public
passer le public quoi
j'enlève mon slip voilà on est
tranquille on est comme ça j'en ai fait
combien de selfies comme ça et je suis
très bien dans mes baskets voilà oui non
mais sauf gros manque de respect
physique je trouve qu'on a pas le droit
de se prendre
tu as la chance de vivre une vie
incroyable il y a des gens qui sont très
contents ou de voir Louane ou qui sont
peut-être ils surréagistes on a pas le
droit de se plaindre c'est un message
bien sûr mais oui bien sûr
un message en disant on n'est pas des
animaux ça envoie une distance ça fait
genre ok vous êtes sympa mais il y a des
limites et c'est pas ça moi je peux vous
dire un truc moi je veux dire il y a des
règles voilà non non il y a des règles
quand tu fais ce métier
je vais dire tu acceptes de faire aussi
des photos tu acceptes de que les gens
te parlent dans la rue comme si parce
que c'est pas ça rien de tricher de dire
et ben tous les soirs je rentre chez
vous et je vous parle parce que je suis
chez vous je suis dans votre salon et
derrière Quand tu es dans la rue tu fais
non non mais c'est bon pas tout de suite
je suis désolé
non mais moi je suis désolé moi même les
mecs qui parlent comme à des potes bah
c'est normal tu es leur pote tu les bois
tous les soirs tu rentres chez eux je
suis désolé
je te dis il y a des règles moi pour moi
ça tu dois pas tu refuses pas une photo
tu refuses pas une vidéo une darka et en
plus c'est sympathique ça va peut-être
jamais ouais c'est plus facile c'est
plus simple c'est mieux de dire oui que
de dire non quand tu commences à dire
non tu vois dans quelle merde tu te mets
sur froides la personne tu crées une
mauvaise ambiance tu repousses quelqu'un
ça te fait mal à toi-même le mieux c'est
de dire oui monsieur boum et puis c'est
terminé il y a un gars qui m'a demandé
un selfie un jour euh qui voilà c'est
c'est je lui ai dit non j'ai repensé
toute la nuit c'était Matthieu Delormeau
[Applaudissements]
sur les réseaux je sais pas pourquoi
elle en prend toujours plein la gueule
10 minutes avant c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé
la raison et si tu veux faire ce métier
là tu peux le maquillage les paillettes
les crossards
d'éducation
il me tape sur les poches pourquoi tu
t'énerves comme ça je suis là parce que
je suis content de te voir là c'est
mignon il a pas l'habitude de te voir
et toi tu voudrais lui dire non mais
dégage comme toi
il demande comme il est lui il demande
naturel parce que c'est la première fois
qu'il voit il s'attend pas mais s'il en
avait rien à [ __ ] de ta gueule il
demanderait pas soit content déjà qu'il
l'avoir on viendra plus voir Mathieu
pour nous tous ici
[Applaudissements]
ils veulent en plus que quand tu vois
dans la rue tu leur dis ça merci merci
tu veux
l'autre bout du monde il faut la
récupérer sur Twitter tu te fasses tu
sais la panse toute la journée non mais
les mecs ouais
tu sais comment elle a été
mais Raymond tu as rebondi sur un truc
que Géraldine elle a dit j'ai ramené la
dictée par semaine
je suis en train de livrer le mec il me
paraît qu'il était mon frère dans la
voiture
parce que là tu arrêtes dans la rue tu
as une casquette des lunettes un machin
et te dire on peut faire un selfie
enlève ta carte
bah oui des fois si la vérité prend du
temps il enlève ces cas sa casquette il
enlève ses lunettes il faut enlever les
lunettes le mec il veut une photo je te
dis il veut pas une photo d'un mec avec
bien sûr mais soyez heureux que le
exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jean-Marie tu vois qui a dit qu'il faut
le faire voilà je vous dis les mecs là
vous comportez comme des starlettes non
arrêtez de vous prendre pour des
starlettes les mecs
j'ai demandé que deux dans ma vie
Belmondo un an dans sa mort et Lewis
Hamilton j'y suis allé j'ai fait ça
trois semaines pour parler
j'ai pas dit poto
tu dis n'importe quoi tu es dans le
milieu les mecs quand ils voient
quelqu'un et moi je peux le comprendre
moi quand je voyais quelqu'un que je
l'ai pas connu je me rappelle moi un
jour j'ai vu Johnny Depp il a été faire
pipi bah j'ai été faire pipi aussi et
c'est ce qui m'a fait dans le milieu
[Rires]
des pirates de Caraïbes tu crois qu'il y
a eu une idée comment la plupart en plus
si tu demandes en disant attention parce
qu'elle petit ouais attention parce que
je voudrais pas que mon compétition
je veux l'enfant aussi et ramène ta
grand-mère aussi
Bernard Montiel en 38 ans je n'ai jamais
refusé bah bien sûr franchement non mais
je sais il y a un mec
en revanche en revanche elle a été
harcelée toute la journée
qui parlaient tout fort qui arrêtait pas
de commenter ce qu'elle faisait
Londres voilà c'est c'est aussi parce
qu'elle avait dit que je voulais pas
faire des photos tout le temps et tout
le monde et c'est ça qui a fait réagir
Bernard que tu fais des photos encore je
suis sûr oui oui bien sûr
mais nous nous les membres du Club
Dorothée on reçoit beaucoup de tendresse
beaucoup de messages de métiers ton
kiffe quand les mecs qui te demande un
selfie et bien sûr
que c'est vrai il m'a envoyé un texto
c'était quand c'était à 3 ans
je sors du resto il est en train de
louer un vélo je vois Justin Bieber ça
c'est pas toute ta vie j'y vais Juliette
est-ce qu'on peut faire un photo il m'a
répondu NAT today Bro alors notre
famille hein tu vas pas le revoir voilà
pas où mais j'enverrai quand même mais
j'ai compris j'ai pas un si tu as pas
dit gros non